.
This man went vegan for just 12 weeks.
Take a look at how his body transformed.
He stopped eating meat, cheese,
and anything else that comes
from an animal.
Sticking to just fruits and veggies,
he went from being in average shape
to having six-pack abs.
This is what giving up meat
and other animal-based products
can do to your body.
And this happened in just three months.
But today, we're going to be giving you
an even bigger challenge.
I have a question for you.
Do vegans live longer?
And if so, how much longer do they live?
0, 4, 10, or 12 years?
Think about that, and we'll have
the answer later in the video.
But for now, we're going
to have you go vegan for a year.
That means no meat, cheese, eggs,
or any other animal-based product.
How could this limited diet
affect your body?
The first week of your new vegan diet
will leave you feeling foggy
and more tired than usual.
This is because your body isn't getting
the same nutrients that you're used to
When you take meat out of your diet,
you won't be getting as much B12.
This has been a massive contributor
of making you feel strong and alert.
You're several weeks into
eating nothing but fruits, vegetables,
and nuts.
And you'll notice that
you’re becoming more, regular.
This is due to the increase of fiber
in your diet.
But on top of all this,
you’re still feeling
slightly sluggish and tired.
“No I mean, I really feel terrible.”
I thought this was supposed to
make you feel better?
Right. It's because you're still
not getting any B12.
This vitamin is only available in
animal-based products.
Some foods like mushrooms
do have some,
but it’s not nearly as much as a steak.
Aw man, I miss steak.
So instead, you'll need to add nutritional
yeast to your cooking.
Not only will it provide you with B12,
but it also adds a nutty flavor
to your food.
Several months into veganism,
any acne you had will start to clear up.
And remember to add some
vitamin D pills to your daily habit.
Without animal-based products,
you've got a severe lack
of vitamin D.
Which has most likely left you feeling
muscle soreness and cramps.
And due to all the vegetables and
non-processed food you've been eating,
you would also see some inches
disappear from your waistline.
After a full year of going vegan
and taking all the necessary vitamins,
you’d start feeling great
Your heart health would be improved
as you'd be eating much fewer
high-cholesterol foods.
Not only that,
but compared to other diets,
you'd have a significantly less chance
of getting cardiovascular diseases
as well as diabetes.
Going vegan can even improve
your gut health, due to all the extra fiber
in your diet.
If done correctly,
by taking the proper vitamins
to supplement what you're
missing from meat,
going vegan can be extremely beneficial
to your health.
Not only would you be making
yourself healthier,
but you could also contribute to making
the planet healthier.
The beef and cattle industry
is one of the main contributors
to global greenhouse gases.
So there's a good chance
you'd miss a juicy hamburger,
but this challenge of going vegan for
a year could ultimately benefit you.
And if you continue to eat like this,
how much longer would you live?
Well, according to the Mayo Clinic,
with a plant-based diet,
you could live an extra four years.
But now I'm kind of bored of vegetables.
What about something
entirely meat-based?
Like a hot dog eating competition?
We'll see what that challenge brings
on another episode of